[Music]
on this friday night it's a covid
christmas eve
holiday travel plans are up in the air
after pandemic staffing shortages ground
thousands of flights it's not really in
our control right while others find ways
around the restrictions holiday
get-togethers off the table the plight
before christmas prepare to launch
nasa's telescope is about to take space
exploration to new heights dream come
true we'll show you canada's critical
contributions to unlocking the mysteries
of the universe
plus tiny treasures hidden in plain
sight i want to stop someone in their
day and think
what meet the secretive street artist
who's delivering a mini masterpiece
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us on one of the busiest travel days of
the year thousands have been left
stranded major airlines are canceling
christmas eve flights blaming a high
number of staff sidelined due to covid19
mike draulie has more on how omicron is
upending holiday travel plans
the omicron variant sure has a way of
dampening the holiday spirit according
to a flight tracking website over three
thousand flights around the world have
been cancelled including hundreds in the
u.s because flight crews have struggled
to stay coveted free i am aware of the
risk that i'm taking by traveling during
this time of year especially with the
variants going around case numbers are
spiking in record numbers around the
world no more so than in the uk which
has now topped a hundred and twenty
thousand daily cases but as shocking as
those numbers are the uk's top doctors
suggest there's a glimmer of hope
because preliminary data suggests that
people with omicron are 50 to 70 percent
less likely to need hospitalization
compared to those with delta there's no
question we are going to see just with
the sheer numbers of patients or in
sheer number of cases we're going to see
more hospitalizations but if those
hospitalizations are short duration
people are recovering quickly and are
able to be discharged they're not ending
up in icu those are the kind of numbers
that we really want to look at and pay
attention to
so while the uk may impose more
restrictions after the holidays prime
minister boris johnson is encouraging
brits to enjoy christmas although the
time for buying presents is
theoretically running out
there is still a wonderful thing you can
give
your family and the whole country and
that is
to get that jab
officials in the chinese city of xi'an
are trying to get their coveted cases
down to zero by imposing a strict
lockdown for its 13 million residents no
one is allowed to leave home except to
by necessities
in northern spain greece and italy
officials have mandated mask wearing
outside
while a strict lockdown has left streets
in the netherlands virtually empty
however many dutch have found a way
around the restrictions by crossing the
border to go shopping in belgium i don't
think we need to feel guilty
because we know we are like smart and
don't do anything stupid to
spread the virus
because no one really wants a holiday in
covet isolation mike durlie global news
toronto
now because of the holiday not all
provinces are providing new covent case
numbers but the regions that are
continue to see record-breaking spread
one of those places again is bc with
more than 2 400 new cases today ontario
hit an all-time high too more than 9 500
that's an increase of nearly 4 000 just
from yesterday and triple the number
reported this time last week manitoba
also set a record with more than 740
though hospitalizations there remain
steady
manitoba's climbing caseload is also
causing a major strain on the testing
system today there was a backlog of 10
000 tests officials there are urging
people to rethink their holiday
gatherings
with these very high case numbers
we have to expect that this will put
significant strain on our health care
system
if we continue these
case numbers this is
imperative that manitobans adjust their
holiday plans yet again
in british columbia the covid testing
system is so overwhelmed that in parts
of the province officials are placing
limits on who can get a pcr test in
populated areas like vancouver tests are
now being reserved for higher risk
people including those over 65 and with
severe
symptoms nunavut has ordered a strict
territory-wide lockdown after detecting
multiple cases there the government says
all indoor gatherings are now banned and
all non-essential businesses must shut
down libraries gyms and churches are
also closed
no matter where you live this christmas
will likely look different between new
restrictions and rising case counts
holiday plans are in flux sophie louis
reports on how canadians are adapting
hopes were high for this holiday season
that family and friends would be able to
get together once again but omicron has
dashed those dreams and suddenly the
guest list is shrinking both my son and
my brother who are supposed to come for
dinner tomorrow
both have covid so they're homesick so
it's just going to be my husband and i
with the new variants sweeping the
country the big gatherings of
pre-pandemic days are mostly cancelled
for another year we're typically very
busy
at christmas all the time people are
entertaining they're hosting however
this year it's been obviously a smaller
scale record high case numbers have put
a chill on celebrations right across
canada we've got flights booked to
hawaii on
january the 9th and uh back on the 21st
now we
we don't know sadly we have a big
christmas party that we usually go to by
my best friend's parents that we do
every single year and we canceled it
and businesses that depend on christmas
parties are facing another season of
uncertainty while canada tries to ride
out this fifth wave of the pandemic
there was a lot of last-minute changes
um people would be having a cocktail
party for 30 or 40 people and you know
the day before two days before they
would change it to individual households
where we would have to deliver
you know cocktail boxes to all the homes
in provinces like bc and quebec even new
year's resolutions to get in shape are
off the table now with gyms shot down
under new restrictions it sucks like
obviously it really sucks for everyone
and especially during this time of the
year where people are just trying to
you know just find some balance and
everyone's eating a lot right now and
having candies and food and stuff like
that there's no sugar coating it this
holiday is another letdown for many but
maybe if we all have ourselves a very
little christmas
next year our troubles will finally be
out of sight sophie louis global news
vancouver
despite the pandemic's long shadow over
the holidays the prime minister tried to
hit a hopeful note in his annual
christmas message to canadians
let's encourage our friends and family
to get their vaccine and booster shots
let's follow public health measures wear
our masks and keep our distances
let's keep being safe and smart and
let's finish the fight against covet 19
so we can build a better future for
everyone
my friends
brighter days are ahead and we'll reach
them together
the pandemic is obviously a key priority
for the prime minister but that's not
the only challenge his government is
facing our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson sat down with justin trudeau
for a wide-ranging interview
2021 was a difficult year for many
canadians for prime minister justin
trudeau it came with unprecedented
challenges both domestic and
international on the home front the
marathon kovid 19 pandemic came with
twists and turns from an initially slow
vaccine rollout to new variants to more
lockdowns and public fatigue the best
thing we can do
to support people is to end this
pandemic for good the prime minister
also called an election which he won but
with the same result as 2019
and if the pandemic and a self-imposed
election didn't throw enough curveballs
foreign policy was a true 2021
flashpoint after the diplomatic standoff
with china that saw the two michaels
imprisoned for nearly three years justin
trudeau says it is time to rethink how
the west handles china
he says allied countries should work
together not just on foreign policy but
also when it comes to business and trade
we've been competing and china has been
from time to time very cleverly playing
us off each other in a in an open market
competitive way
we need to do a better job of working
together and standing strong so that
china can't you know play the angles and
divide us one against the other
despite that the prime minister would
not give a time frame for when the
canadian government will decide whether
to allow huawei to build 5g
infrastructure in canada or whether it
will borrow it on 5g completely but mr
trudeau did say that ottawa is looking
at china differently than when he first
took office in 2015. but i think we're
going into it with a very
vivid understanding of the way modern
china operates we'll also talk about
what the prime minister called mission
impossible for former defense minister
harjit sajin dealing with sexual
misconduct and toxic power dynamics in
the military and the denials mr trudeau
says top military commanders engaged in
we'll also talk about whether canada is
doing enough fast enough to help
vulnerable afghans who protected
canadian soldiers and what the two
michael said to the prime minister when
they finally touched down in canada
after years in chinese prisons look for
our special presentation of in
conversation with the prime minister
tomorrow on global news and again sunday
on the west block mercedes stephenson
global news ottawa
still ahead exoplanets excitement
nasa's new telescope gets ready for
liftoff
[Music]
welcome back this christmas scientists
are especially excited tomorrow morning
after years of delays the
state-of-the-art james webb space
telescope is scheduled to launch the 10
billion dollar project has the potential
to reveal new secrets of the universe by
providing a view of space never seen
before as eric sorensen reports canada
is playing a key role
it's going to go all the way to this
point that we call l2 lisa dang is one
excited exoplanet expert among the first
who will use the james webb space
telescope when it reaches its new home
one and a half million kilometers from
earth this is a truly i don't know dream
come true canada has contributed two key
instruments a guidance sensor to focus
on distant galaxies and an imager to
probe new planets lisa deng will study
one hot planet with oceans of lava and a
rock vapor atmosphere for the first time
we're going to look at the interaction
between oceans a crust a mantle and the
core of a planet and the atmosphere of a
planet the launch will be one of the
most important in the history of space
exploration thirty years in development
the webb telescope will look further out
and further back in time to answer the
most basic questions how did we get here
and are we alone we're going to see
towards the beginning of the universe
closer than ever before with webb the
canadian space agency is a major partner
with nasa and the european space agency
so canada will be at the forefront of
new discoveries in space canada has
access to five percent of the entire
observation time of the whole
observatory so
the canadian scientists during that
period will actually get to decide where
it's pointing what images it's taking
and they will have privileged access to
these images one canadian scientist will
study the formation of a nearby galaxy
this really is a wonderful mission of
discovery it's just seeing the universe
with these new eyes gives us
deeper insights into
things we never would have expected webb
will replace this the hubble telescope
the new space telescope is a hundred
times more powerful with a mirror that
must unfold outside the rocket it's
outfitted with a solar shield to block
heat and light but will be so far beyond
the moon that it can't be fixed if
anything goes wrong we're not going to
have the second chance
like we did with hubble so it has to
work on the first go and that's what
makes the next month of space flight
nerve-wracking for scientists all over
the world i'm really just
on the edge of my seat the nervousness
starts with the expected liftoff
tomorrow morning eric sorensen global
news toronto
what if all three of your vaccine doses
are different brands still ahead the
experts answer your covid questions
bc's provincial health officer had a
message today for those considering
whether to ignore public health advice
and attend large gatherings with friends
and family over the holidays dr bonnie
henry says there's still so much we
don't know about omicron
omochromis is different it is spreading
in a way that is very different from
previous variants in a sense we're in a
different game a different pandemic now
and the one big question that we don't
have yet and fully understand yet is how
severe this is going to get
what's the impact going to be on our
hospitals and speaking of questions all
week viewers have been sending in their
questions to us about the new variant
and to help answer some of your covid
christmas questions we are joined now by
epidemiologist dr christopher labos who
joins me now from montreal dr labos
thanks so much for joining us let's get
right to the first question and a timely
one for those planning to sit down for
some christmas dinner this evening this
one comes from jack who asks can you get
infected if someone who is infected were
to breathe or cough or handle your food
so from what we know no
it's not transmitted in food you can't
contaminate someone's food the issue
with family gatherings and gathering
around a meal is that you're sitting
around the table with people who are all
breathing the same air as you so that's
the real danger it's not really a
question of contact meaning you're
touching surfaces or you're eating
contaminated food or anything of that
kind
okay good to know and another question
this one from joanne of course a lot of
people wondering how they can socialize
safely over the holidays she wants to
know are you okay not wearing a mask if
you're outside talking with people for
say five to ten minutes and you're not
social distancing
yeah that's probably okay i mean here's
the thing we have to remember enough
it's never a question of safe or
dangerous it's always a question of
degrees of risk so if you're outside the
risk is significantly decreased that
being said it's still
there is still some value in keeping a
bit of a distance from people if you're
outside in a large crowd surrounded by
people and you're in close contact with
them that's probably not ideal but if
you can keep at least a respectful
distance and you're outside the risk of
one person passing covert onto another
is probably pretty low especially if you
keep that interaction short like only a
few minutes long
okay uh next question comes from jan
we've received a lot of questions like
this one uh people concerned about
mixing doses especially as they go to
get their booster shot so for jan she's
in nova scotia
where there are more moderna shots and
her first shot was astrazeneca second
was pfizer are there any considerations
or implications in mixing thrice over
uh the short answer is uh no there
doesn't the we look pfizer and modernist
seem to be interchangeable and there's
no real reason to prefer one over the
other and there's no harm if you've got
you know an astrazeneca followed by
something else so i wouldn't worry about
this in any way shape or form
right this next question comes from
karen and obviously one that a lot of
people are wondering is that people try
and get their hands on those precious
rapid tests but karen's been hearing
more and more about the high rate of
false negatives that we see with the
rapid tests so why is it that these
tests are still being promoted as a way
to know whether it's safe to gather
so the rapid tests are not perfect there
can be false negatives and there can be
false positives so they're not perfect
but they are still useful so we
shouldn't overstate their benefit but we
shouldn't understate it either it is a
useful test if you use it in conjunction
with everything else so if you have if
you are fully vaccinated you've gotten
your booster you're wearing a mask
you're keeping gathering small you're in
a well-ventilated area and everybody at
that around that table tests negative
that's one extra layer of protection so
remember it's not perfect but a test
doesn't have to be perfect in order to
be useful
yeah i remember seeing one analysis
that's that found that i think was about
60 percent effectiveness for those rapid
antigen tests for people without
symptoms so as you say an imperfect tool
but an important one nonetheless last
question for you comes from ken who says
that at the beginning of the pandemic
there was some talk about achieving herd
immunity and ken wants to know will we
ever reach and achieve herd immunity
well it sort of depends it depends on
the virus it depends on the new variance
it depends what the ultimate level of
vaccination rate we achieve we still
have a ways to go before we vaccinate
the entire population so we're really
not quite there yet and you know the
point of hurt immunity is not that the
virus is going to disappear the point of
hurt immunity is that we have enough
vaccinated people to protect a small
number of people who can't be vaccinated
so i think the short answer is that
question is we will wait and see i don't
think anybody really knows how this
pandemic is going to play out over the
next six to 12 months
yeah one thing we've learned to expect
is the unexpected that's for sure over
the past couple of years dr christopher
lavos in montreal thank you so much for
taking the time to chat with us
especially on christmas eve really
appreciate it merry christmas
merry christmas to you too
next a feast for the eyes hidden in
plain sight
[Music]
well take a look at this a drone
captured this bird's eye view of festive
fort st john bc transformed into a
winter wonderland to support the
salvation army
it really is a beautiful time of year
though in the cold of winter you can be
forgiven for keeping your head down but
one ottawa artist is trying to change
that she calls herself street art
miniature or sam for short and as
michael couture explains sam is hoping
people will take a moment to take in the
beauty of their surroundings
it's been said that art is all around us
even if we hardly notice while hunched
over our phones
the size of some murals or sculptures
make them hard to miss but if you look
hard enough around ottawa you'll find
some masterpieces are many
these little clay creations are hidden
around ottawa in plain sight however
they're hard to spot because most are
the size of a dime or fingernail and
making them is no easy task a lollipop
can take a couple of minutes something
like a charcuterie board though could
take up to three to four hours depending
on the different pieces she goes by sam
or street art miniature the civil
servant works surreptitiously so we've
agreed to keep her identity secret
often she'll place a piece at night or
quickly during the day and like other
street artists she wants her work to be
the focus i want to stop someone in
their day and think what why is that
there a tiny hot dog on a brick wall
that's strange the juxtaposition of it
is just so odd
she does give clues about where she's
left the clay carvings and the minis
have a major following john normando has
hunted them with his partner since 2017
and they head out every time there's a
new post
you want to go see it in person
just to
appreciate it in person but also we
found that we really started
appreciating the actual hunt itself as
well normando isn't her only fan the
makers of a locally made milk-based
vodka collaborated with sam for a major
mini marketing campaign obviously we're
not going to be able to compete with the
big guys in terms of spending so we have
to do something that's a little
different and a little interesting and
you know if it could also mean
supporting a local artist and
doing something fun then all the better
and that's sam's goal to bring a little
fun to people's day especially during
the pandemic trying to encourage people
to go out and explore their
neighborhoods and just go for a walk get
some fresh air
try to enjoy yourself during this time
and to keep an eye on your surroundings
because you never know what you may find
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
making me hungry that is global national
for this christmas eve i'm jeff semple
we know it's been a difficult time so we
wanted to leave you tonight with a
little levity we asked you our global
news community to capture your furry
friends wearing their festive best and
you delivered cats dogs even budgies
showing off their christmas spirit so
thank you for sharing those and thank
you for watching colleen christy will be
at the anchor desk here tomorrow have a
safe and merry christmas and a happy new
year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you